the world's tallest male teenager just
committed to the University of Florida
to play basketball his name is Olivier
Rue and he's 7 fo6 which makes him
taller than Shaq Wei and Yao he's
originally from Quebec Canada and he
plays for IMG Academy and not
surprisingly he's been tall for
basically his whole life he was
recognized by the Guinness World Records
for the tallest living male teenager
he's been compared to another
seven-footer that you probably remember
from last year's college basketball
season Zack Eddie Olivia's game is not
nearly as polished as the produced St
but there is one thing you can't teach
in basketball it's being 7 foot 6